cities will be the capital city of our
belter nation
a place all belters can be proud of
and forever call
home
all through philip's life from his very
first memories the belt had meant the
outer planet's alliance and the opa had
meant the people that mattered most his
people it was only as he'd grown up and
started being allowed to listen when his
father spoke with other adults that his
understanding of the opa became deeper
more nuanced and the word that redefined
his people was alliance not republic not
unity government not nation alliance the
free navy was not the opa and it was not
meant to be the free navy was the
strongest of the old order forged
together into a force that didn't need
an enemy to define it it was a promise
of a future in which the yoke of the
past was not only shrugged off but
broken hey guys pete here the expanse is
back for its final run and this is my
breakdown of season six episode one a
half of a year has passed since the
battle of soul gate and things are
pretty dark it turns out that the
constant threat of the next asteroid
hitting and the degradation of the
biosphere are keeping things dire on
earth six months in a ship either
chasing or hiding with a bounty on your
head isn't great for morale but hey the
free navy is feeling pretty good about
where they're at and we got a whole new
planet a new tree of life and everything
although things could have went better
for mother bird there i'm gonna recap
everything that happened in episode 1
which was titled strange dogs and then
we'll get into what it all means and
where things may be headed for this
final season for a quick spoiler warning
if you haven't watched the premiere of
season 6 yet then this video won't be
for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it season six opens on
the planet laconia which is in the
system of the same name this is where
the martian breakaway fleet decided to
call home and where they took that
active proto-molecule sample that they
traded those fancy mcrn ships to the
free navy for we meet kara a young girl
who's grown up on the planet she's
hanging out in the forest she's taking
in all the alien wildlife that exists
there and she gives some of her snack to
a mother sunbird that had brought her
babies out of the nest she hears
rustling in the bushes and she discovers
a little creature that she thinks looks
like a dog and as she's checking that
out she hears the mother bird shriek and
it's clear that there's something
seriously wrong with it she picks it up
and runs away and the camera pulls away
from the surface in this great shot
where we zoom out and then zoom in on
the orbital platforms that we saw at the
end of season five which is of course an
artifact left behind by the gate builder
civilization the episode proper opens
with a sort of newsreel montage that
shows that there are still rocks being
hurled at earth you see multiple new
impacts and we'll learn that those are
fragments of rocks that they shot down
and these have caused casualties in the
millions the experts are predicting
severe biosphere damage and so if it
wasn't clear at the end of season 5 the
people on earth are suffering and things
are getting worse rather than better
there's footage of people rallying
behind marco and the free navy in the
belt several stations have declared
their loyalty and survivors of the
palestinian attack bow revenge so way to
go pastor you probably should have
listened to abasarala there's also a
chiron that reads the un strikes back
the rossi joins the fight and then we
get the first callback character who had
a few memorable appearances in season 1
including the speech on series where he
laid out the unsavory conditions of life
as a belter and called our man miller
out for working for the inners here he
says now earthers know what it feels
like to be belter and you can see the
point that he's making out in space you
see some rocks get shot down by a
railgun barrage coordinated between mars
and earth then on the surface of the
planet we catch up with bobby draper
christian avasarala and a new member of
her staff apparently they've knocked
down every rock marco has thrown at them
for the last six months but secondary
fragments still make it through which is
causing a lot of problems and with so
many individual strikes continuing to
come that's kept their entire fleet
pinned to the planet to aid in the
defense
earth and mars are working on new ships
but none of this makes abasarala feel
better they're looking on at a
high-yield grain farm and it's clearly
not producing any food and she remarks
it's like a goddamn nuclear winter the
biospheric data is grim and the bottom
line is that each rock is killing them a
little more even when they miss and
don't forget the psychological effect
that this would have on everyone on the
planet all of that's to say that the
free navy is winning and on series we
see that philip's enjoying his new
celebrity at least the part where it
makes him popular with the women marco
has a meeting with two new characters
sandrani and rosenfeld they're both
connected to opa factions that threw in
with the free navy and they're talking
about how earth is too busy knocking
down their rocks to have any real
presence in the belt sandrani talks
about upping the food production on
ceres and it's pretty clear that marco's
not that interested in the
administrative side of things and here
we get some really bad news when we find
out that anderson dawes is dead marcos
says this is because he got tired of
listening to him and i gotta say it's a
little bit disappointing that this
happened off screen after i first saw
this i was holding out hope that we
might get something in that x-ray mini
episode that they were going to put out
but alas it doesn't look like we'll be
getting any more anderson dawes so rest
in peace as they continue to talk it
becomes clear that rosenfeld is very
close to everything that's going on and
she tells marco they got rid of some
dissenters but they haven't been able to
find drummer he decides to up the bounty
by twenty percent on her and the ross
ante philip has a new friend and marco
makes the speech when a crowd forms
around him it's been years since he's
been on series but he considers it a
home now that they have control of it it
will become the capital city of our
belter nation a place all belters can be
proud of and forever call home the crowd
cheers and as philip looks on he looks
sort of messed up later we'll see him
and yawn bring two girls over and when
they ask about the attacks on earth
philip starts to freak out and has to
leave the room and in a conversation
between rosenfeld and marco she says
that ceres is not medina that they owe
these people nothing and it's here where
you start to see that the free navy
isn't really about helping everyone as
much as it is about taking power she
says the people on series can tighten up
on their rations which sounds a lot like
what earth did to them when they were in
charge and when philip objects to this
marco basically ignores him and takes
the meeting somewhere else so they can
talk in private later we'll see that
philip is continuing to spiral we see
him drinking at that same bar again and
continuing to hit on the bartender who
turned him down earlier she's diplomatic
but not interested and he freaks out and
acts like a jerk he throws a drink at
the wall and starts shouting about being
a hero how he killed the earther until
his friend comes in and tries to get him
to leave they get into a fight and when
philip starts losing he pulls out his
gun he shoots and he kills jones which
brings his story to an end so rest in
peace there we hardly got to know you
and your alligator best elsewhere in the
belt a free navy bounty hunter has
located the dewalt from drummer's fleet
and is getting ready to board it he says
he knows the tynan is there too and
tells them to show themselves or be
destroyed it turns out they're using
that as a decoy with drummer joseph and
michio planning an attack from the
hidden tainan when the time comes michio
hits the wrong button which makes for a
tense situation and drummer has to act
fast to destroy the dewalt to take the
ship out in the aftermath we find out
they were only able to salvage one
missile from it and that brings their
grand total to three so things are
pretty rough for them at this point
later they discussed their limited
options on where they could go to refuel
and to re-arm and joseph brings up
michio saying that she's a liability in
so many words she costs them a ship and
she's not cut out for what they're
dealing with alternatively he says that
he's a fighter now as drummer always was
and that this is not a place for michio
anymore drummer's not convinced and she
brings up the fact that they've lost so
much already which is absolutely the
case with serge getting spaced by marco
oxona and bartol leaving and even though
this would bring them to being a family
of two at that point she still decides
that they'll leave michio behind when
they find a safe place to dock and
refuel
the rossi is on a recon mission in the
belt they're engaged with two free navy
affiliated belter ships that they
destroy and they've been at this for 187
days and you can see that on their faces
they're tired alex's death is hanging
over the mall holden is currently in the
pilot's chair it appears that they're
investigating the ongoing rock attacks
and when they look at the one that's
there they come to the conclusion that
there's no way that the ships they just
destroyed would have been able to throw
them in earth's direction holden wants
to get closer but naomi insists on
sending a drone rather than approaching
it directly this sequence serves to
catch us up on the crew dynamics you get
the idea that clarissa keeps to herself
below and that she's become a reliable
mechanic working under amos he provides
some really great space porn when he
goes outside to look for damage and
provides us with a nice dramatic moment
when he stops to look at the plaque on
his way out and the drone discovers that
there's a drive mounted on the surface
of the rock which holden decides to go
down to investigate they're trying to
figure out how these things are
triggered since just about anyone could
make one if they were willing to give up
a drive and with the free navy capturing
so many colony ships there are plenty of
those to go around there's a touching
moment when naomi realizes this is the
first time that she's flown the
rasanante it's the first time she had to
because alex was always there and you
can see that she's struggling with it
when holden opens the box connected to
the drive he triggers a fail-safe and it
starts up he gets tipped off when a
piece of metal is attracted to the
magnetic bottle naomi knows that this is
gonna kill him and she begs him to get
away but he starts beating on it instead
and is able to break it in the nick of
time when we go back inside we can see
that clarissa is avoiding being around
naomi and when amos brings it up they
get into an argument naomi says the only
reason she's here is because you made
her part of the crew as if that could
replace alex it ends with him saying
maybe you could cut peaches a break like
we all did for you and she just tells
them that he should find somewhere else
to be at that point later holden
discovers footage of the bar keith
disappearing as it goes through the ring
the red flashes remind him of the
artifact on illus and amos is quick to
say that it's not their problem anymore
he doesn't even want to hear about it
really he says he's only out there to
kill marco before he kills us and that
the only reason he's there is that he
didn't want to abandon holden so he
pleads for holden not to abandon them
naomi comes in to let them know that
she's found out that the rock with the
drive was waiting for a launch signal
from a spottership they discovered that
previous bursts like the one it was
waiting for were coming from an orbit
from a specialized ship that's running
dark if they could take that out they
would drastically reduce marco's ability
to keep the inner planet's fleets pinned
down so they plan to find it and when
they're alone holden apologizes to naomi
for not being more careful on the rock
and she explains why she's so off she
says that she tried to stay away from
the violence for so long and then marco
pulled her back in now they're hunting
down belters and she doesn't know how
much longer she can bear it and finally
we see that avasarala is on a ship
called the xenobia monica stewart's
there and she's poking her a bit asking
her if it's true that she reached out to
marco for a peace treaty and she forces
abu sarah to say that all marco has to
offer her is his unconditional surrender
in their heated back and forth we get
reminded that the colonies have been cut
off from communication since the battle
of seoul gate and then bobby steps in to
cut her off later when they're alone she
tells bobby she knows she hates this job
and tells her that they got a message
from holden about the azure dragon
spottership she breaks into a monologue
about how their wounded broken trying
desperately to keep going by pretending
we're not little wins here and there
won't hold us together we need something
more than that something big something
to give a reason to hope and when bobby
asked her if she has something in mind
she says she does and we see the rossi
crew getting strapped in at that same
time they destroy the rock on their way
out and the episode ends there
it was a strong episode in that it had a
lot to do to catch us up with where
everyone was at now that six months has
passed a lot of that is conveyed in how
beat down the crew is and it was a
little unsettling when i watched the
episode for the first time not that it
didn't make sense because it does
they've lost alex and they're doing a
thankless job with only small gains that
haven't been turning the tide clarissa
is still a point of contention and amos
seems divided in his loyalties which is
a weird place for him to be they are a
family and you do see that they have the
ability to push each other's buttons
when they want to for me it just took
some time to adjust to that as a book
reader it was great to see laconia and
get introduced to kara and the strange
dog there was also another mention of
laconia when rosenfeld and marco were
walking away from philip she said that
medina needed more titanium because the
laconian pieces had been harder to
install than they anticipated so that's
something to remember drummer's
situation is absolutely bleak which
again makes perfect sense but you kinda
hate to see it her line that we lost so
much already is what got me started on
making the drummer video i put out
yesterday and it's definitely difficult
to see her breaking up her family even
more philip has never been a favorite
character of mine beyond how his
existence affects naomi's story but i
like them deciding to show him
struggling with his place in things he
played a major role in killing a lot of
people and he watched what he thought
was his mother committing suicide as a
last resort to get away from them only
to find out later that she was still
alive he's definitely feeling those
things and now he's done something else
that's going to contribute even more
marco seems very pleased with himself
and it does feel that rosenfeld's
influence isn't something that makes him
better they mentioned the issues with
food on series a number of times and it
seems surprising that she was so
indifferent about it the good news is
that abba sarala has a plan it involves
bobby leaving where she's at now and
doing something that's more upper alley
which is always a plus and it's not hard
to put together where that's going so
the table is set things are only gonna
pick up from here and i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
what you thought about the episode what
you think about the season so far and
how you're hoping things are gonna play
out in the comments please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon